[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
guys should be able to hear me
I hope so
I really do I really hope so
and I hope you guys can hear
I know the screen looks a little crazy
but it's going to look like that until
dirt gets here
I'm not changing stuff just to change it
back when dirt gets here
that dirt gets here
you guys just gonna have to deal with it
because I'm not changing it it's not
happening
my mic is quiet
is that better
is the mic quality improving
I hate this arm I really do
I can't stand this arm sometimes
red falls on is out in four months can't
wait Starfield
what's going on guys you know you guys
are really shown this is like the
pre-show right now I'm waiting for dirt
now
something really weird going on with um
with zoom right now
I don't know why but it's like being
very
gimmicky
no I don't have issues assumed to that
degree
uh but we're having issues today like
tremendously
I don't know what that's about
I don't even know if it's letting dirt
in in the game in the call
it's very very weird
can you guys hear me fine though
all right so it is going to let dirt in
the call
but
can dirt hear me
all right but I can't hear you hold up
no I can hear you they can't hear you
and let's make sure the default is set
for the headset now talk
go ahead and talk
yo yo yo what's up everybody we good we
good right now
yeah I was having some serious issues
with
with zoom I don't know what zoom's
problem is right now
but I'm definitely having issues with
him
so uh this is uh a little bit of a
pre-show you know we'll start in a
couple minutes this is just me
testing everything
and now we're going to make you wait to
the Fantastic uh
bars
of Dallas see you in a second
[Music]
thank you
what's going on guys
it's it's it's it's it feels like it's
been forever Derek yeah
we got some stuff to talk about this
week
I think at this point saying stuff is an
understatement this week saying stuff
really feels like an understatement you
know there are some serious stuff going
on man and we we got to talk about it
but anyway
let's go ahead and uh introduce yourself
man what you've been doing what you've
been playing man what's what's going on
what's up man well I was um
literally playing some redfall before
the podcast I played normal last night
yeah I just finished um Dead Island two
great game loved it I loved it I loved
it uh but that's about it man
I played
redfall for about I would say
two hours two two and a half three hours
last night how much time are you having
rifle
about the same about three three four
hours or different perspectives because
we're different people huh
all right so uh
welcome guys to the attic show we talk
about the past present future gaming got
my co-host with me Dirk Gregory you know
we're we're just gonna we're just gonna
get on with the show you know because uh
we did a little bit of an intro and
there's a lot to go over and you guys
know how I am I like to get in and out
you know like like to be like to be
surgical with this man like like to go
straight for the juggling then just walk
out the back door I'm the Hitman of
podcasting all right so
first thing we're going to go we're
going to start with a little easy you
know we're gonna start a little easy
because there's a lot to talk about
today and I feel like let's let's put
our feet in the water before we just
jump straight in with a cannonball
um there's there's some there's some
stuff going on about hellblade have you
have you seen what these rumors going
around of a hellblade
yes sir watch watch the video about it
oh you watch my video I see I'm
educating these people man I've been
trying with the content man like I've
been putting out a video like almost
every day yeah man I've been noticing
two weeks
I've been I've been grinding that stuff
man five dollar Super Chat from Corey
todwell uh damn my bird dirt looked like
a dog ran away keep your head all right
what you talking about man I'm having
fun here man is that like I'm happy to
be here I'm enjoying myself what you
talking about brother
yeah I feel like you got like a weird
relationship with some of your views
yeah man I see a couple of them here
like
the homie Makai saying dirt is hurt come
on man you talking about
yeah so what am I hurt by
all right so there's been this game pass
commercial
and this game pass commercial
was playing a lot of games is coming out
this year
um I was told there was some kind of
marketing saying it was 2023 games
but the interesting part of this
is hellblade was in this commercial now
obviously they could be talking about
how blade one but the odds of that being
the case is so slim that's a 2017 game
man yeah and that but they did have sea
thieves in it well but that's not going
game that's an ongoing game I would
think that's a little bit different and
and ninja uh the Ninja Theory made that
before they even bought them
so I I don't think they would use uh
content that was made off their umbrella
it's just it's interesting that you
would see something like this now
remember uh we've been reporting on the
attic show for a while that you know
hellblate is a possibility for 2023.
it's definitely been in the conversation
for a minute for a little bit uh so the
first thing I want to hear your opinion
on is like
what do you think that that's possible
first off and second off
do you think Xbox needs that this year
yeah sure why not I mean
um I do think it's possible because like
you mentioned that's something we've
talked about several times already
um you say you heard heard some stuff
like maybe it's 2023
you know we're thinking like is it 2023
you know we know they were done with the
motion capture uh last year of the whole
game they were done with all the mo cap
of the game last year and last November
I believe
um uh was it early 2021 uh I'm sorry
like June 2021 or maybe
May April um the head the head of the
studio to me not I can't pronounce his
last name
um he said they're working on the
gameplay slice and then they're in full
production now that was in 2021 and we
know what the gameplay sliced was that
was that the vga's 2021 so it will be
two years uh it's definitely possible
that they're done with the game
and your other question about does Xbox
need it of course
that'll be dope man I believe if if you
know Starfield is a banger for some
older spoilers of Banger and we get help
late too
people will forget about the stumble
that was real rare fall we'll get more
into it fall yeah
I feel like hellblade is definitely a
must this year and I do feel like
the state of Xbox
you know we'll get into a little bit but
I do feel like it it needs a little bit
of Revival uh obviously Starfield will
be a very good look and I think
I think starfield's gonna deliver you
know I know
it's easy to do in the Gloom right now
and I know it's easy to point out the
negatives uh because there's so many
uh but
this is I need to do a little bit more
research in RK because I feel like I've
been told they used to be one Studio
then they split into two I don't know
about the logistics of that but
yes we will get to the state of Xbox
okay that is a topic but right now we're
talking about hell blade
I feel like hellblade is in that vein
that people love that that third person
over the shoulder action adventure game
and that game being handled correctly on
top of a star field I feel like would be
a very good one-two punch
and I do think they need that good
publicity I really do
yeah
so there's not really a whole lot to go
on that you know what let's let's get
percentage man
percentage-wise what do you think
hellblade 2 drops and keep in mind that
there's this like weird wiggle room that
they can do where it's like okay you
know technically it's in 2023 but this
is they can be like put 2024 the
beginnings through the financial year of
2023 so yeah you know maybe they'll try
to pull something like that which would
you be okay if like they came out this
June and they're like
hellblade February like 8th
yeah I mean I think as long as they
don't announce like a huge huge
six months like as long as they have the
release date and we see enough gameplay
where we feel confident this game is
Click I think people would be fine a
February release date I think people
want a November release date and I think
there's at this point them putting that
in the commercial is very interesting
because they didn't have to put that in
the commercial and if you looked at that
because I went through when I made the
video there's no fabled in that there's
no the outer worlds too in that right
there's no Perfect Dark no vowed
there there's no contraband
um there's there's no Elder Scrolls six
because they could have easily thrown
that in there so it's interesting that
these large portfolio games no
compulsions game which they they haven't
announced that so they can't really put
that out there but
no ever while
uh so I feel like there is something
there if they're not if they put that in
there because that seems very selective
and the majority of those games are
either out this year or out at the end
uh near the beginning of this year or
the end of last year five dollar sweep
drive from Corey Tidwell dirt you know
I'm not a hater but damn redfall sucks
uh it was worse than America uh a monk
you stand up Monique Monique stand up I
play I play for four hours and damn near
reinstalled Windows what does that mean
reinstall when does that mean it was
like it was like messing up your if he
was playing on PC I heard PC is much
worse than Xbox
on both oh did you yeah I played on like
the windows thing
and we'll we'll get to redfall uh you
know I think I will put a little bit of
uh you know impressions in the uh the uh
the after the redfall aftermath
uh so I think we can move on man let's
yeah
let's move on for some reason I have no
you asked me a percentage though didn't
you oh yeah I'm sorry I just completely
threw me off
yeah what's your percentage man I I tell
mine after yours
I right down the middle I think it's 50
50.
I I hope you know I 50 uh percent me
thinking it will drop this year the
other 50 early next year either way
would be fine by me and like you said if
if like next month at the Showcase they
show a nice gameplay slice and they say
hellblade to come in February so that'll
be fine bro that'll be fine because I do
believe it will come out early next year
um
I'm actually gonna surprise you I'm
gonna say 70 30.
that's 70 that it drops this year yeah
cause to me
you got some balls putting that in in
that kind of game pass like a game that
you know because if you think about I
know a lot of people like to like
look at the fact we haven't seen a lot
of combat under microscope but we've
seen a lot of hellblade yeah yeah and I
think that out of everything we've ever
seen because if you look at it compared
to everything else we've seen more
hellblade than we've seen like quadruple
or fable we've seen one thing of the
vowel one thing of fabled and there are
CGI cut scenes and we ain't see nothing
else Perfect Dark
that's that's a given at this point I
don't think we're expecting that game
anything I think at this point we need
to see more of those games and I I think
the fact that there that they went out
there and they're like yo
let's put this in there and that's
interesting man that's interesting I I'm
curious to see if that ends up turning
up and I think
redfall definitely was a hit it it was
like it was like a stumble roll it
wasn't just like a hit it's like you got
hit you stumbled and then like you know
like you almost catch yourself from
falling down some crazy stuff that's
gonna really mess you up they didn't
catch themselves they roll down it so
and I think that that would be a good
look to really start catching back up
there of course we got Jada you know JW
don't show up unless it's bad Xbox news
five dollar Super Chat for j-dub uh
waiting for more mid games ain't gonna
fix it they don't have it in them time
to put Xbox out of its measure all right
all right hey man hey man how's that
PlayStation roadmap looking what games
y'all got oh me got some dates Thanks
for y'all games you got some dates yeah
you J dub okay can you come to the front
of the uh the Congressional how y'all
roadmap looking that's Spider-Man two
I'm sure that game would be pretty good
I'm sure Wolverine
dude we got a release date for that
that's right yeah play for that
Spider-Man he ain't seen it damn that
damn thing yeah you know but they got
that too dirt that's what they got
I don't know man I don't know what what
has it Jada what's going on man what's
going on I don't know I mean man we can
assume a lot of stuff you know they got
that God of War Ragnarok plus five
wait a minute how about a showcase
yeah maybe there's showcase would
announcement showcase this month man we
hitting the inside sayings this month is
this my man so much uh damn what days I
don't know maybe J dub knows what day is
this okay
come on jado
uh we're asking you questions that are
not hearing answers it's like that thing
where I'm talking in like those little
cups with the string and I'm sitting
here giving all these questions
and where is the answer hey look at it
these guys funny road maps just look at
the library they look at the library
what about the future
look man
look at j-do he's gone he's M.I.A I need
people to put a APB is that what they
call when you call for the police say on
J dub I want to picture him on milk
carts that says Where have you seen this
man
hey yo my boy my boy final crack how
about that psvr you know what y'all got
a bunch of psvr games you know right you
know what
my bad psvr has a bunch of games I'm
sorry guys yeah you know what you're
gonna have JW you're gonna have a bunch
of
live action
you know you know I'm about to say don't
you live action
free to play Live service games is that
what you want Jada oh yeah you know
because I feel like the only the only
stuff we hear the
what is that j-dub you know tell me what
you looking forward to man you know
instead of coming at me over a redfall
justfully you know Microsoft gave you
the gun oh here we go five dollar Super
Chat from Jada when you're number one
you can do what you want on your own
pace Xbox is on life support oh man I
feel you know what's on life support
though the future of PlayStation games
um you know all them games as a service
they got coming hey naughty dog had all
the I had all that turnover rate man
there's so many people left Naughty Dog
where's their next game
uh well when did when did when did Last
of Us two come out
three three years
where's the where where's the
announcement Jada
when goes to sushima come out
that's a question
not to be fair tonight this can age very
bad they can we ain't here tomorrow we
we throwing a Spirit Bomb uh Jada are we
going for the gut punches win then ghost
Oh shushima Come Out chat hit me up man
tell me what you know it's a funny
addict they know it's a funny addict
I've been doing this show with you for
about what six to seven eight months now
the last two weeks the first time I seen
JW you know he in that chat he just he
hiding he hiding under the ground and
the moment he sees he's going for that
Achilles heel you ever seen that movie
with the people living in the walls that
like cut your your Achilles heel and you
fall and then they just stab you on and
over there yeah no man what movie is
that yeah I don't know man I can't
remember what the movie's called see J
dub goes through the Keeley Hill but he
messes up and just and just cuts a
little bit of the skin above it and you
just look at him he's just looking at
you and he's like oh oh I missed
lost my damn top oh I think your camera
turned off too yeah yeah I cut it off oh
okay okay
he's looking all over okay we we we uh
nah man we done man we we done we done
Jada unless you unless unless you feel
like you still want that smoke you know
because I feel bad for you Jada I do I
feel bad for you you know we playing we
playing the the definitely underwhelming
games right now but you know what's
better
than playing underwhelming games
apparently playing nothing at all
People Under the Stairs about me I used
to like that movie I ain't seen it since
the 90s though two dollars Super Chat
from jelly to have People Under the
Stairs yeah what's funny is I always be
telling people and I know Jade I've got
like a really bad
uh Persona on Twitter I don't know why
he does that uh he's not really like
that in real life
but uh he's not a bad dude he's not a
bad dude I just don't know why he always
like he lives and breathes to make
people mad
uh so when you read these super chats my
brother is bugging me he don't he wants
me to come over there for a second I got
it
Kendrick star with the five hopefully
Xboxes is burning off the old crappy
gangs before releasing uh the showing
the big games the Xbox and Bethesda
showcase
Deus Ex uh what's that macchiato uh with
the five factions is M.I.A wasn't that
coming out with the last of us too hey
yo talk that you know what I'm not on my
channel I gotta be careful
the angry therapist with the five I'm
enjoying red fault ain't as bad as
people saying but when Spider-Man came
out with bugs it was considered fun
you know I got to be honest Spider-Man
was was polished game um
redfall you know honestly but well we'll
talk about it shortly uh my thoughts
about redfar
but um you know everything you know
everything isn't perfect
as of right now but uh
saying some of the things I'm seeing on
Twitter
it's ridiculous man it's absolutely
ridiculous
I'm sorry guys you're back
yeah my brother uh because we we have uh
carpet our new place and he has these
big filthy ass boots on he don't want to
walk through it so he asked me to get
him something I couldn't find it I'm
sure you guys heard me a little bit
was there any good super chats the JW
talk his smack again or is he hiding no
no I mean you know I hate chilling he
chilling all right so let's
let's get into it man
um let's talk about Xbox going forward
uh where are we right now we're 36
minutes and 30 seconds uh get that for
the time stamp Mafia you know you know
what's funny
the time step Mafia in you know there
are very scary organization
they did nothing but complain when I
have those thumbnails but where is the
thank you addict in the in the comment
section where is the you you go above
and beyond for us so we want to make
sure that we give you your flowers
where's my flowers
but I bet you 20 bucks if I didn't do
those thumbnails they'll be right back
in there I mean those time stamps all
right let's talk about it
you know we ain't gonna go too much in a
red ball we still got a topic for that
did we get all the super chats uh I
believe I got them yeah okay I
appreciate that uh my brother get on my
nerves all right
now with
the
the perception of redfall because people
individual people can like redfall
clearly the the industry as a whole
don't uh so where do you think they go
from here
um you know just continue to now you
mean Arcane or Xbox as a company as a
brand Xbox is the company and Arcane
we'll make it too let's get I'm gonna
check real quick five dollars from
Butterball I like that name actually we
will be for uh forgiven when redacted
comes out thanks for the timestamps this
is
thank you man you gave me my flowers
Butterball
Butterball you think you live you you
the goat you the VIP content he gave you
your props man
okay so to your question I believe
Arcane Austin will continue to patch and
continue to work on the game we we know
they have some DLC coming some extra
characters and stuff like that I believe
the game will be running much better
um in the future you know it should have
been ready at launch but unfortunately
it wasn't polished at launch
um I believe Xbox
you know their future is still bright
like I said earlier this is just a like
you mentioned it's just a little stumble
you know this little like they're
jogging down the street and they tripped
over you know something and they failed
this is a pretty big trip though like
you may can see like the stuff they told
and they fell it's like that that
dramatic like
I think everything seemed worse because
of the time it hits
um CMA blocking the deal last week is I
feel you know bad Xbox news you know
it's definitely a stumble
um but I mean hell man um you know we
can't seriously rare fall is trash that
means Xbox would never have another good
game ever I think that is too hard that
is too far like but that's what people
are saying
I feel you but at this point dirt
because of hey Knicks
why are you lucky ain't on my channel if
you ever come to my channel you already
blocked just shut up
[Music]
him I told you man time him out you know
I think we brought them on my channel
stretch your thing man you know next he
ain't done nothing to me but if you if
you if you want to feel like you want to
jab them a little bit you know make them
make them wait like what is it like a
minute and and I think there has no
expectations how many many do ask me a
question I'm answering his question
this is because I don't oh oh I give you
want me to be one of those guys fine
Phil Spencer that oh that's what you
want me to be I get it you want me to be
one of those guys speaking Field Spencer
Xbox needs to be started five mad booty
you're you're not gonna get that for me
speaking of that you know people they
want someone to answer to this
are you who who do you think the blame
lies on like who do you personally feel
like needs uh quote unquote like you
know the head's rolling where you know
there's consequences for games
conditions coming out like this like
what what do you think is who do you
think because a lot of people put a lot
of the blame on Phil Spencer uh then
there's people that put the blame on
Matt booty
um this is Bethesda I think this is more
on p uh Peter Himes or Pete Himes I
don't think this is really a Matt booty
thing now if you want to talk about the
initiative that's him that's 100 him
um
I my personal opinion I think this is
like
70 percent P times P because he's the
part he's pretty much the matte booty
over there to my knowledge maybe it's
someone else and I'm just ignorant to
think and it's like 40 uh
uh Phil Spencer because it's like
here's the thing UH 60 40. that's that's
what I'm thinking because when it comes
to this
it's Peter hein's fault that he didn't
keep that room in check and it's Phil
Spencer's fault for not keeping him in
check to keep that room in check you
know um
redfall was supposed to be a bigger game
than it is and that's just how it is
uh you know we'll get more into like our
Impressions on redfall and stuff
to me
do you think right now as it is there
needs to be management change on the
upper echelon not the studios but the
people managing the studios Okay explain
explain why well first of all let me go
back to your first question
the the blame is all of the above right
we can you know like we see how Xbox and
Bethesda yes Xbox Microsoft uh owns them
but they're still letting them run
themselves as a publisher right so one
we can definitely blame Bethesda but at
the same time
is the marketing person who is the
person is the time time see I always see
Pete Himes like I see like
when no but no when when Aaron Greenberg
was when that thing with Bethesda he
said some chick there was his equivalent
remember that
that chick was talking and he's like
that's my equivalent and he's like we
need to get together and find out
maybe I'm not sure I feel like if P
Hines is in marketing I feel like he's
got more than one role because every
time you talk you see Bethesda talking
in terms and stuff like that Pete Heinz
is the one that's talking this MP is the
head of publishing so
um okay so Peter's the head of
publishing it's what a couple of guys
are saying yeah I don't think this is
Todd Howard's fault I'm not putting the
blame on Todd Howard I don't yeah you
know if if if uh Starfield comes out and
it's buggy and doesn't work and it's
underperforming that's Todd Howard's
fault that's actually that's how this is
the thing that's talk Howard's fault
Pete Heinz fought Phil Spencer's fine
yeah
this is the thing though
um well so let me finish this point like
before I get to one comment I just think
uh you can blame Arcane Bethesda whoever
right so you can also blame Xbox field
spin some mad booty because maybe
they're not Hands-On enough right
um they're they're like giving these
Studios carte blanche to do what they
want to do what you want to do do the
game right so they're hands off
so maybe they need to be a little more
Hands-On I know Matt booty really is
hands on with the Xbox game studio uh
teams you know double fine you know uh
initiative all those guys over there
um but but there's the still runs
themselves so like I said maybe field
experiencing my booty or whoever or
specifically Phil Spencer should have
been a little bit more Hands-On maybe
babysitting the project a little bit
more so I would say all the above
deserves some blame for the red for our
situation now there's a guy what was
this uh where's this
Super Chat
see this is the thing that really annoys
me sometimes
I I lost a super chat but he said it's
an Xbox business like well like he said
something like Xbox has been spending
billions and billions of dollars for
years and they had nothing to show for
it listen 2022 no excuses dry dry as a
desert no excuses
but
um
they won publisher of the year yeah you
can't take away for 2021. that's what
I'm saying these guys look once I get it
some of those games weren't exclusive I
get it but true you can't take away from
what their Studios did maybe it doesn't
do so much for the Xbox platform but
their Studios continue dirt sorry if I
don't know yeah no you're absolutely
right and um guy guys they conveniently
forget certain things now listen man I
will be the first to admit yes I know
I'm a bot but I would be the first to
admit you know about the Xbox one
generation there were some times they
wasn't developing games how they should
have been and because of that it's been
taking forever for these games to drop
that we're getting now right
true fine but just the point of people
conveniently ignoring 2021 people bash
Halo infinite all they want to but that
game still got it at 87 metacriting yeah
people forget that like yeah just
because the the the live service didn't
work afterwards and it released polish
man it released polish
it released polish very few bugs it was
just uh like you said the the content
was taking forever and things of that
nature but I'm just saying Psychonauts
two that game was like 80 what 87 88
something around there I know that you
know they were developing the game
before Xbox right
they were developing the game with Xbox
so I'm just saying that yes nothing's
perfect
yes they still have a tough road ahead
of them
um yes redfall was definitely a um
stumble
but it happens to the best though it was
a trip it was a trip to me it was a trip
it was a trip okay okay
so it was a trip okay but now they got
to get back up wipe the dust off of
themselves and move forward
right whistle put some like peroxide on
her hands and heal their wounds imagine
like Xbox coming down like there's
there's like Bethesda trip fell down and
Xbox comes down there was like the
bandages and the peroxide it's okay
now this guy Frank can't say redfar is
an establish the curb stomp okay so what
is for smoking then is that a curbstone
also or are you going to run with it
that's not first party uh but I do you
think see here's the thing there is some
give to that argument there isn't some
give to that argument because it's just
like
for spoken isn't made by an Xbox
PlayStation Studio but it was approved
by PlayStation Executives yes
PlayStation one up there and they played
that game and they said that's it lit
drop it
um I do believe that
for the most part
PlayStation wouldn't let their first
party come out like this yeah and
Microsoft needs to do a better job uh
you know I agree I agree
people are sitting there I'm I'm there
with you right now I am there with you I
don't think management needs to change
currently because I do think that there
are some of these titles that are just
naturally because I think Jeff Grubb
reported that Microsoft never believed
in redfall or something like that and
yeah uh they pretty much let this game
come out to die so it's kind of crazy
they they let it get delayed here's the
thing like if you have games like this
there's better ways to approach this
they could have came out there maybe
it's because they don't want to support
it long term
maybe they they they literally plan on
supporting this for a certain amount of
time and to just cut it you know what
I'm saying
um
put it in the preview program you know
we're working on this type of but I
don't know if they want to support it
long enough to fix it so it's just like
look
do you think it would have been better
for iPhone let's not talk about redfo
we're still talking about the future all
right let's
let's talk about
Phil Spencer management
let's say Starfield comes out
doesn't do as bad as breitfall because I
think it would be really hard you have
to be really trying at this point uh
I personally feel like right now the
management
at Xbox this is more on Bethesda Xbox is
definitely gonna take the heat they
justifly should because they should have
delayed the game but I don't think they
were willing to fund this game any
longer
they're like let this come out let it
burn everyone
you know everyone touching this plate
getting burnt everyone
but Burns Hill and they're like I'd
rather it out
we get through the pr
and we move on with our lives and I
think part of the issue too is it was
just a really bad time for this to
happen you know yeah the time it was
terrible if this month didn't happen and
you know if that if the the ABK deal
approved last month uh last week I don't
think this kind of energy would be going
into this but it wouldn't begin as much
heat and and the current is like look
they deserve all this heat and that's
why I'm okay with the heat because it's
like dude like
how you
it's hard to really sit here
and tell people that Xbox is the brand
they should be supporting
when
we don't really get the kind of
experiences like that like
Minecraft Legends is a fun game but it
wasn't for me and you you state you see
stuff like redfall and you look at that
game and you're like all right
it's hard to continue fighting
that narrative that they're just
throwing stuff in game pass because they
know they're not going to make the money
that they could because it's in Game
Pass and you know I'm not saying this is
every title but you keep giving that
narrative more and more energy when you
release more and more games like redfall
in it
and to me
you are kind of setting up Game Pass to
be you know I love when Jack moving them
say uh Game Pass fodder and it's like
look like even though if you do not
expect that to happen
and you do have
plans to release quality games in Game
Pass you are taking the wins out of
those future cells because you keep
making the narrative worse every game
you release if if Minecraft Legends is
like a really successful game now
obviously it's going to be successful
commercially because it's Minecraft and
anything Minecraft in it does extremely
well but it's just like Microsoft's got
to do a better job with pushing a good
message and sometimes you know I don't
know about you Dirk
I'm going to ask you uh you know we're
still going to talk a little bit about
redfall in our experiences where I fall
do you think rifle should have just been
canceled
no
okay explain
no because this is a game that should
have been canceled is absolutely
unplayable like
I believe there's some fun to be halfway
where for it's just the game release
unpolished
I think the characters are cool
um it's you know it definitely has
issues I think I love the atmosphere no
I don't think it should have been
canceled at all so I'm friends with
Travis over that IGN and he's like one
of the few people in the media that I
trust reviewing games because he's
actually hard on games I actually feel
like the industry is too easy on giving
like nines and tens out of tens like you
should see very few nine to ten out of
tens like most of the time you should
realistically see seven and eights but I
feel like these industries are so
comfortable giving stuff 10 out of 10
like all the time like there's been
multiple Call of Duty 10 out of tens uh
and I think I think he was like look
like I've seen a lot of games I've
played a lot of games early in
development and I personally feel like
even a couple years wouldn't have fixed
this because he felt like a lot of the
issues with this game is on the
foundation level
and he just didn't enjoy it and I I see
a lot of people agreeing with that
mentality and like look
I'm never gonna ask for a game to be
canceled I'm never gonna ask for that
but I do think that
if a game is going to affect your
perception in the industry
and it's going to make people maybe not
uh maybe not trust the type of games
that you put out like for the most part
when PlayStation releases a game now
they have dots like uh you know one
could say
for spoken's definitely one of those but
for the most part when PlayStation
releases the game especially first party
people don't go in there with caution
people go in there with excitement and
sure maybe once they're in there they
get disappointed if they don't like the
game but I see very few times when a
PlayStation game releases it is met with
caution
I love days gone though and that game
was a 71 metacriter but I loved it and I
think
the problem that I'm seeing now
is that you're giving these narratives
more and more energy with you can
release broken games because the game
pass the game doesn't have to be
polished because the game passed and I'm
thinking you're hurting Game Pass you're
holding Xbox you're hurting the
perception of your first party titles
you're you're you're looking at this
from like a negative standpoint when
why'd they buy Bethesda in the first big
game keep in mind not only is this the
first big game for Bethesda that we got
from Microsoft is the first 70 title
that we got on the Xbox platform and
that is that's what I feel is the
biggest issue is the perception that
redfall gives it it's one thing you're
not saying though
now you said now you said here you said
how PlayStation first party they have uh
okay a pedigree of being quality right
Arcane has also they're not saying that
game so well but let's see every Arcane
game was in the high 80s with the
exception of this one I saw people
giving Arcane those flowers though like
I saw BG saying yo I'm expecting 80 plus
because normally they don't miss I saw a
lot of people giving that energy and
would you not saying because even though
this is like the B team this isn't the
team that made like death Loop and
Dishonored uh apparently the students
they still may pray though yeah it's
apparently the two the studio split into
two
um would you agree that letting them
come out redfall might have hurt
arcane's image and maybe the next game
won't even do well because people are so
cautious to that brand now what I only I
mean when you you know if you're known
for a great quality and then you you
know have a slip up
like people will look at the your next
title kind of like okay now
I don't want to see you know another f
up again so yeah yeah I mean you you do
look like you know at a team or like a
person that messes up just like like you
pay your credit right if you're you know
if you're paying your bills on time then
you mess up for a month you pay it past
30 days late past 60 days late the the
credit bureau was like hey
your credit is going to dip a little bit
because you paid a couple late even
though like in the past you got all you
know you paid a month every time so yeah
you you do look at them if they stumble
you know it's like you know just like
anything else in life so yeah
I feel you I think me too it's like I'm
a big fan of Dishonored and I loved uh
death loop I love the majority of their
games I I didn't gravitate towards
praise much and I probably should read
it too yeah but I do think that the
biggest thing that I don't want is I
don't want
something like redfall that could have
been canceled to say the reputation of
the studio
like have a domino effect that they
release the game
uh you know and a lot you can argue
unfinished and unpolished and it led to
the studio becoming like a support
Studio instead of like a studio making
games and I think that's my biggest fear
and that's not like the whole arcade and
talk about this particular team like if
I had my way I would say look
put them back together put Arcane left
and Arcane right and fuse to make arcane
Super Saiyan back again right yeah it's
like you don't they don't want to be
separate you know and I think that's the
biggest issue I'm having too is I don't
like
Xbox highly encouraging small teams to
make small games you know it's okay to
do one but I see people trying to do
like two or three
and like Ninja Theory got like three
projects four projects and it's just
like I'm
the sole thing that I feel like there
should be a a team and A B Team the a
teams and I don't think that just
because you're working on a B Team means
you're working on like a really small
title I feel like you that should be the
smaller team like right now
one we could say the Bethesda software
the the core Bethesda is working on
Starfield and they have a small team
working on Elder Scrolls 6. when
starfield's finished they will rotate to
Elder Scrolls and towards the end of the
end of the cycle that small team will
rotate to their next game and they'll
finish Elder Scrolls 6. that's how I
feel like the studio should be right now
of
obviously when it comes to something
like this
you got to give Studios
the option to flex the creative muscle
uh that's how you're going to get stuff
like Hi-Fi Rush even though I'm not the
biggest fan of ground I think it's a fun
game
ground is a successful product and
that's the one thing I do want to point
out
red following me into my eyes is a
complete failure like commercial wise I
I think I don't think it's going to do
well for perception wise I don't think
it's going to do our rating wise it's
going to be a game that people look at
as like
the really black one uh like what's the
one I'm looking for
like a really
bad game like I think people are gonna
like kind of like look at it like the
battlefield uh you know 2042 I know the
the cyberpunk like people are going to
say stuff like that when it comes to it
and my thing is like even though this
game did that and even though
yeah the black sheep that's what I was
saying they're gonna look at as like the
black sheep you know that game uh that
people don't really look too much into
even though redfall didn't do this like
we can't act like Microsoft hasn't had
hits
grounded
um Wasteland three 80 plus grounded did
well too uh pindiman even though I don't
like that game 80 plus on finnamon you
know
redfall is definitely going to scar
Bethesda it's gonna It's Gonna Hurt
Bethesda it's gonna scar Xbox but I
don't think it's the end of the world I
don't I think people are exaggerating to
a point but I do think that Microsoft
deserves the smoke all the smoke they're
getting they deserve it because someone
looked at redfall and said that's hot
melon and I think that's wrong because I
think
us is Xbox content creators Xbox Gamers
Xbox people consumers we don't deserve
games like redfall even if
even if that game was functional at 60
frames you look at that game
and it doesn't scream Arcane to me it
doesn't scream AAA products to me it
doesn't Scream the way they were
promoting the game to me
I feel like the way they do the
marketing the pr was very deceitful uh
you know I know people that went to like
the preview stuff and what they played
wasn't what we got I did I feel like it
was complete deception and they should
feel ashamed of themselves and stuff
like this what it ends up doing is it
makes you feel very wary when you
support another product
starfield's coming out redfall has
nothing to do with Starfield but
starfield's going to get the backlash
because now and obviously you got people
that's going to use this anyway to
attack them but there are people
generally concerned about Starfield now
because they're like look you can't
expect me to be a hundred percent
have faith in you
when you're showing us something like
red phone they really promoted this game
dirt like hardcore and I agree with them
like I I do it's like I said I don't
think it's the end of the world
I don't
but I do think the people that are
generally concerned that it's a key
Point generally I don't want to hear
people that's doing
the I'm a talk [__] because it neither
gives me money or it gives me enjoyment
I want to hear from the people that
generally want the product and the brand
to do well and they're concerned those
only people I care about
uh so it is what it is like I get it
one thing
I don't want people to be a hundred
percent on Arcane for this
I don't want people to be 100 on
Bethesda and Microsoft for this
I do think redfall is not acceptable but
at the same time we can't attack Fable
because of this game we can't attack
Starfield because of this game let those
games come out and Define themselves
now Starfield comes out
I will say this at Starfield we have a
show coming up June the 11th if so let
me ask you this
if Starfield comes out and it's
underwhelming and the show comes out and
they don't show us nothing
do you think there's any a need for a
member uh a leadership change then
if the show comes out and they don't
show us anything no not like nothing but
it's just like a bunch of fluff you know
years before we get like a bunch of
indie games and they'll show us like
little things but they don't show us
anything enticing anything that that
that that that that good good stuff man
they just that would be a bad look and
then
Starfield just looks mad and it comes
out and it doesn't really Captivate
anyone do you think at that point
we might need to start talking about
leadership changes
yeah probably like like probably you
know Matt Booty like okay what are you
doing are you are you getting these
teams ready you know like where were
these games
at the Showcase yeah yeah probably at
that point I mean even you know some
people say we need to look and feel if
that happens you know that's that's
something if if their show
is man they don't show now they don't
show anything that's gonna happen but
that that's of course it's not gonna
happen but yeah yeah man you have to you
know really because you can't keep on
yeah pretty much so all right so you
know
I do wanna
I do want to talk about
um
the
our predictions on
just small predictions I don't want to
go too much into it
um that show was officially announced
today
yes and um where we're an hour and four
minutes so I I don't want this to be
long uh because we'll probably do
maybe six minutes in this and we'll
spend about 15 minutes on on redfall
because we've talked about redfall a
little bit already
uh so
the it was announced man you know we
finally got the the event it was finally
formally announced you know
how do you feel about this going into
this you know we're about a month away
from it a little bit over a month uh do
you are you anticipating this or uh what
What's your hopes for this you know I
don't want to go into expectations your
predictions but what do you hope to for
Microsoft to achieve by the end of this
event
I want um
there's there's a negative stigma
surrounding the brand right now
or you know redfall for the CMA blocking
the deal you know things that's been
happening within the last month like I
put on Twitter it's been a rough month
for us Bots
um
to make it positive again because coming
into the generation Xbox had a little
momentum they did and I feel like they
did a very good job promoting the series
consoles yeah but then 2022 happened
where the momentum they lost the
momentum because they had no AAA games
and then they started and then they got
a little bit more positive momentum at
the beginning of this year with Hi-Fi
rush and and the uh what's it called
like the um developers direct then they
got a little bit more positive momentum
but then you know this last few weeks
with like I said with the CMA blocked
the deal and redfall things it started
really with the redfall 30 FPS that's
when
everything just started going down so
the numbers CMA blocking the deal yeah
yeah so yeah it's been crazy man over
again yeah so
the Showcase needs to make people feel
good feel positive by Xbox again right
that's what they need to do they have to
you know show some dope hellblade 2
Gameplay people want to see Fable I'm
not sure favor will be there
but they want to see something something
they want to see some new announcements
what is compulsion game what is
Coalition working on you know what I'm
saying what is n Exile working on what
about Contraband we want to see some of
that so
I really feel that they need to do that
to get people to change their negative
feeling about Xbox at the moment
what do you personally feel like
what's the one I'm looking for
what do you
feel like Xbox
need
what do you what do they need to show in
the Showcase like uh you know and let's
keep it realistic you know because this
we're not doing our predictions but you
as watching now what do you feel like
they could show to really generate some
some excitement and get people back on
their side at this event they can show
some gameplay from some announce games
right they can show some gameplay from
about and it just totally blows people
away oh my God you know we've seen a lot
of hellblade too but some dope combat
um some end game you know some actual
gameplay from the game showing some
combat from the game
um just something that really
you know just
blows people away Perfect Dark will be
incredible I don't think they'll be
there I hope I'm wrong but that'll be
that'll be incredible
um and even with games like hell play
and The Vow a release date
would be phenomenal don't know how
possible that will be but for them to
have a release date
that would make a lot of people happy
I think that they need to stick to to
gameplay
now obviously I do feel like you need to
abandon that 12 month thing
don't do that please don't do that yeah
yeah yeah you know you don't have to
show a lot from the like the long term
future though like show maybe a game
maybe two
uh but I do think the focus of the show
needs to show on
we understand that a lot of you are
upset with this
we understand a lot of you are concerned
with the games you're going to play on
our platform
but
these are the games that we think you're
going to enjoy
um
they've
they have no problem in the past showing
us gameplay like a year like two years
before it came out like I think we've
seen gears two years before it came out
like physical gameplay
you know I'm not the biggest thing about
vertical slices and I'm okay with it a
little bit as long as it makes sense but
I don't want them to do vertical slices
of of stuff that's not in the game I
hate when they do that when they do a
vertical slice of a section that's not
in the game
and it's just like at this point though
I do think that hellblades got to be
there and it's got to show heavy
gameplay I do think that
you know we need to see Indiana Jones
and it would be very beneficial if it
said at the end of that XBox exclusive
I
the biggest thing I'm concerned with is
the Starfield attached to it
uh you know I think I've spoke this
concern before I just feel like having
Starfield like that
and having
the Showcase attached to it like right
after
most the time when you when you have
really good stuff you don't want to you
don't want to like share the spotlight
with anything
and to me
why would you attach star fill to your
show
let's say the star feels just
overwhelmingly positive
what do you think people are going to
talk about on Twitter write about
like the Starfield coverage
obviously there's people still going to
talk about the the actual game but
uh the games that that's really to me
I personally feel like and this is a bad
feeling on my end I hope I'm wrong
I feel like they added them together
because either they're both going to be
average as hell
or one is underwhelming and they need
the other one to Hype the other one up
no I think I think you're overthinking
it bro it's just I don't understand why
you wouldn't like
drop that direct at the end of the month
like the end of this month
build up hype and then drop your
showcase
I don't understand why they're putting
them together
because that that doesn't happen when's
the last time you saw
a like a Nintendo Direct well I mean
Nintendo does it but Nintendo's weird
they they do stuff all the time when's
the last time you saw like a PlayStation
showcase followed directly by like a
Spider-Man gameplay uh direct uh state
of play you know what I'm saying like
it's not I mean the average thing that
they do but they don't have to be the
same as Nintendo PlayStation right okay
so listen
they're like maybe they are looking at
it listen two hours of Xbox greatness
you know we're showing you the future
games we're showing you the games is
going to drop next year some this year
maybe we're going to focus on our huge
AAA game that's dropping this year
should they have separated it
put the um like the uh like the
Starfield Direct in August Maybe
but they're doing it all at once I mean
so I mean that's good for us we got two
hours just to sit there and it's oh yeah
definitely good for Content creators
well it's definitely got you on
screenshot from Panic is boss gains with
release dates are needed I agree with
you 100 agree with you and I'm not
saying that's like the end of the world
thing I'm just I'm just concerned for
putting two shows close together like
that because normally they don't do that
they they don't want to share the
spotlight yeah I guess maybe because
they're considering up both of theirs
they're not really sharing the spotlight
with anything but it's just like to me
if you want to stay consistent in the
news why didn't you release that a week
beforehand because to me the way I'm
looking at it and it's like I said I'm
probably wrong you don't want either one
of them sitting out on its own being
covered you want them together for some
reason and to me it just doesn't make
sense
okay um
damn I think I was about to say
[__]
I think I was about to say this man go
ahead someone said Gears of War six that
would be interesting that'd be crazy if
they ended with gear six now I don't
want them to end the gear six part of me
wants to end with like a new IP or
something it'd be cool uh but it's going
to be interesting we'll have a
prediction thing
um oh didn't I say what day was going to
be I don't remember because it's only a
month away bro it's crazy I think it's
the we'll do it like two one two weeks
before uh yeah uh it comes let's let's
talk about red fault man let's talk
about redfall we got an hour
bam and then we got
13 minutes bam
let's talk about redfall all right so
you we both got about the same amount
two to three hours into it give me your
impressions on my fall okay I'm gonna be
100 honest at first when the game first
started I was like like the controls
seemed a little off it was too quick too
loose
so what is going on but to make the long
story short and I kept on playing it
and um oh I'm going to start off with
the positives right because they say
when you critique something to always
start off with the positives
I love the atmosphere I love being in a
small town going into some homes looting
um you know just walking around town uh
I do like the environment of the
atmosphere the music is fire
um the 30 I would be honest the 30 is is
actually kind of smooth for 30 FPS
I don't know maybe it's just me but the
30 FPS same kind of smooth I felt that
way too I felt like the performance is
still shaky at best but I did feel a
little bit like this game played better
than a lot of other 30 frame games yeah
yeah
um now the negatives I will say
um
I like how the environment looks but the
graphics like the NPCs
they don't look good at all you know the
NPCs don't look good at all
um so the graphics are in but they
didn't get Arcane they're not known for
their Graphics anyway but
I haven't run into a lot of bugs but one
I have run into
um like when you would use the right
analog state to look around sometimes it
will stutter like when I would look
around with stutter like what the hell
bro did you get like nauseous playing
this any like right now no I was getting
nauseous
oh so maybe the 30 FPS is is bothering
you know I think it was mainly because I
put up my field of view
oh yeah okay that was probably making me
feel like I was gonna throw up like okay
I didn't feel nauseous I don't stop
running like I felt like I was running
like
I didn't need
is it me or you run too fast in that
game you do run fast yeah I feel like
you're running faster than cars yeah you
do run fast yeah like we we don't we
don't even need cars in that game like
remember the issue we was having in uh
and what's that game called uh the
division yeah there's no bikes and we're
running everywhere just make them all
run like you do in redfall we have no
more issues yeah because I feel like
vampires have no first off uh are you
let me finish let you finish yours and
then I'll go over mine okay and and the
last negative thing I have
um the AI is horrendous bro the AI is
super broad they walked I would walk in
the room where I while they're there
they'll turn around and look at me
[Music]
on the human AI is pretty uh bad the
vampires I haven't run into any
vampires not putting up a fight but I
will say there was one cool vampire I
ran into called the siphon it's like
deciphers
no this person was in like on like top
of a building it was by a checkpoint I
was going to a checkpoint to unlock the
checkpoint there's purple stuff at you
no they're taking your blood away it's
like just kind of like no not the one
shooting the purple stuff I've seen that
one in
um in the basement no not that one but
it she was just taking blood away from
me disciping siphoning my blood away and
that was a cool uh boss
um but and it's also a little easy well
like the human it's it's a little easy
right now I haven't played Co-op yet but
some of the vampires I think are pretty
cool
um but you know like I said honestly
right now playing three to four hours of
it it probably is at this point a six
out of ten for me at this point
but I'm still early so
all right so I'm bureau if you uninstall
the game
um it was making me very nauseous and I
think
I think it was the motion blurry you can
turn the motion blur off and it didn't
seem to happen yeah you can
um
I feel like
the the the guns didn't feel good
uh the movement didn't feel good it felt
clunky at times
I also feel like the characters
were kind of half written because if you
like you look at the names like look at
the names of the characters
I feel like the only person that to me
got any form of background story was
Jacob Jacob the undead or the undead eye
right you know what they call homegirl
uh they say uh the one in your
background what's her name Layla Layla
you know what they say on hers it's
Layla the student in debt what yeah yeah
they did what that's true yeah how how
is Jacob Jacob with the undead eye that
sounds good
and then you you switch over one Layla
the student in debt what
I'm just like wow like to me this is how
I would have preferred it all right yeah
I feel like they should have just based
us off one character made it a single
player game
and you know have the other characters
there but their support characters
it's just like to me
it felt like this game didn't know what
it wanted during development for so long
and by the time they narrowed it down it
was too late
uh because there's a lot of good
Concepts in redfall a lot of good
Concepts like the beginning when you see
the wall of water even though the water
looked really bad to some degree that's
cool imagine if you would have seen
there keep in mind there's almost no
cutscenes in this entire game but
imagine if you would have seen like a in
delt cinematic in detail cinematic and
it shows that chick with the fire head
and like you trying to run and she just
shows up and she's like you're got going
anywhere and she just holds her hand up
and just raises the water and just
freezes it in time like
I feel like if they would have put more
time
they would have wrote a better story
and well I haven't beat the game I don't
know the story to that degree to make a
comment on that but Graphics definitely
should have been upgraded significantly
I do feel like maybe
Maybe
focus on one character
and you know really build the other ones
up to that one character
I feel like we would be talking about a
redfall 2 right now
uh it it does feel like they try to make
this more of a co-op experience yeah and
they didn't grab what makes Co-op fun
you know what I'm saying like because to
some degree you can't have a co-op
experience
and like a real Co-op experience and say
you could play by yourself
because to me at that point
no one what's the point then it's not a
co-op experience if you don't have to
play it with someone
like look at like the best games it's
ever been Co-op even though you guys
don't like it Resident Evil 5 you had to
play it with someone uh it takes two
had to play it with someone a ways out
how to play it with someone like most of
the time when you have a well-made co-op
experience that is like Game of the Year
Worthy
it is
mandatory to play with that person sure
it could be a you know computer it
doesn't have to be a real person you
know a ways out you actually did have to
be a real person but I just feel like
it personally to me it did feel like
they didn't know what they wanted to do
for a little bit of the
of the store of the development cycle
when they figured it out there wasn't
enough time to Define what they wanted
to do so it had to be like a mainly uh
you know very that's what I'm looking
for
a very like centered game where it was
it was okay at a bunch of things but it
wasn't good or great at anything you
know what I'm saying I understand
I understand hey
and let me say this um
the world is empty right but it makes
sense
because the story is they evacuated the
town so do you think they could have put
more ads in the game though
yeah maybe but
um but it makes sense I mean they're
like like it's like death stranding
right
it's empty but it makes sense right
um so people say it's an empty world yes
you're not going to see people going to
the store they evacuated the town
I agree with you uh it is nicer when
they do stuff like that when they give
you reasons why yeah yeah so you know I
saw some people saying it was always
empty man I'm like come on bro you
didn't feel like you could have had more
resistance there you know what I'm
saying where like you know how it is
especially white people you know you're
getting these things they I'm gonna
fight them back like it's just like I
feel like you could have had more stuff
going on that like you know more kind of
like Rebellion teams because like look
at something like Sunset Overdrive it it
was in a band of town they kind of
evacuated that whole area
um and the survivors just made it work
and yeah it felt like
an actual
place that you had to survive in
I'm gonna be real with you this game mad
easy
especially how dumb the AI are I'm
walking up not even trying to go and
cover not trying to hide I'm just
walking up pile stab pow stab like
it was I will say what I did play with
it with like friends besides me getting
nauseous it was pretty fun it was okay
uh but I don't think this is something
that everyone's gonna like I think for
the most part
I think when you start comparing not
redfall on its own is okay at best but
when you start comparing it to other
stuff you can play that's when it starts
to fall real short yeah yeah it's it's
not a um
top tier game like I said what I played
so far it is around a six out of ten but
it's definitely not a one out of ten
like some people are making it out to be
you know it's not their best effort it's
not our King's best ever yeah you just
want to say like to me it's six out of
ten but I'm going to continue to play it
because it's not the worst game I've
ever played um so I'm going to continue
to play it man I ain't gonna be real
with you man I I didn't install this you
say you can I installed this sucker yeah
I understand bro you know I understand
I'm never gonna tell people uh you know
they shouldn't they shouldn't attack or
play something you got like you like I
won't be playing it
and everything but it's just like if
when I started getting nauseous I just
knew I couldn't continue
like you know I was helping call play it
so he could try out the co-op because
he's doing some stuff undefining Duke
but it's just like to me I just I just
couldn't keep doing it I was generally
about to die playing redfall like my
head was getting red
I was getting light-headed I was
concerned for my safety I was five
seconds away playing redfall about to
call an ambulance to come get my ass
like I don't know what it was because
games don't normally do that to me but
I was I was struggling man I was sitting
there like here's my controller it's
this messed up black one right here I
was like I was like this up
we're all different people because I you
know I love the game like recording that
game was destroyed right all right I see
people Butterball say at least you
didn't break your embargo like some
people
like if that's a if that's a a jab at
ACG don't come in with that stuff you
don't realize how many stuff people were
juggling
it's easy to put something in the wrong
scheduled date and then press continue
it's so easy to do it you know how many
times I've accidentally put up a like
time zone mess-ups where they said
Pacific and I was like oh 10 a.m Eastern
and they meant they made they meant one
but I'm in eastern so I broke embargo
and then they're like whoa I I'm gonna
need you to private the video
uh I hate that it happened ACG and you
know that sucks
it happens it's so calm people don't
realize how easy that is
people don't realize how easy that is
it is so easy to mess up on stuff like
that and you know and for the people
talking like look I get you up out of
there keep going about that man like
you know a ACG probably beating him up
self enough like don't come at him with
that stuff
hey man this guy said ACD is a messenger
of troop and I love his reviews I
guarantee this this guy said he's a
messenger of Truth until he buys a
PlayStation game
oh my God man so
when it comes to to redfall do you think
it's gonna think it's gonna affect
anything
uh honestly uh
no if if they're so if they showcase is
solid if Starfield looks great they'll
be fine and if you know the APK deal I
don't want to talk about that but you
know the people still see me think it's
going to go through so yeah if that goes
through
we're still confident it's going to go
through so I think if the EU approves it
it's still definitely a chance if the EU
dads it it's dead bro if the EU says no
it's dead it's cool Butterball I I knew
there's a bunch of people that broke it
and I just wanted you to know that as a
content creator and someone that handles
ndas it is extremely easy to do that I
remember kid smooth I think it was
Assassin's Creed posting mad content no
there's Far Cry posted mad content and
he had the pr person hit him up because
he messed up on the time zones and he
was asleep and he woke up it was like
because he was going to uh no he was
going to work he was driving he caused
me attic I need you to go in there right
because I'm a manager on his channel I
need to go in there right now I need you
to private every Far Cry five or six
whatever it wants video and yeah I had
to go in there and do that man like
oh my God these super chats they're
going at me five dollars
five dollar Super Chat from nuisance
nuisance yes uh shout out to attic for
scouting dirt for the show smart move
red Falls should have forced Co-op like
take two Dead PlayStation has no games
y'all bees
new future you ain't wrong there
I appreciate that man I'm just I'm just
informing people that it's not sometimes
you mess up especially handling as much
as someone like ACG does he doesn't have
like an entire like a writing team and
an editor team like he does the majority
of that himself and he's good man he's
pretty good uh we gotta find out the
Super Chat from stay high FFF hey attic
your gameplay of Jedi Survivor made me
nauseous yeah I was struggling there at
the beginning when I was fighting the
ninth sister I was getting better there
towards the end but it was taking me a
minute to get used to that timing yeah I
gotta get into that I had bought it but
I I wanted to focus on redfall first we
got to fight off yeah from G stealth
I've been hearing that uh YouTubers that
read fall trashy or dirt but I've been
playing it and I haven't had no problem
yeah it's like I said I'm never gonna
tell you that if you like it you like it
you know
people got different tastes I might
question your taste but I'm not going to
tell you you don't have a taste in games
it's up to you you know some people
think x-coms are trash and I think some
of the best games ever like those turn
bases there you go uh grid Space games
so I feel you on that I do
I mean when it comes to this Dart I just
want Xbox to straighten up the ship you
know we
they're never gonna truly compete with
PlayStation releasing games like redfall
and especially for full price six uh
seventy dollars
because that's the biggest thing imagine
that man
imagine a 70 dollar game you buy it and
you get red fall because right now it's
easy for us to like kind of water under
the bridge when it's game passing you
know we're just getting the game for
Subscription Service like imagine if you
bought redfall for seventy dollars if
you started playing that sucker it's
like that that oh I made a mistake and I
think that's the biggest issue and it's
like we said last week where you know
maybe
Game Pass is starting to become a
double-wedged sword uh you know and that
it's not necessarily on
the quality games that go into it
because some people in there are saying
you know broken games going to other
services all the time they don't go in
the game pass that's true and I think
we're having an issue with this the
industry in General on broken games like
for some reason companies love giving us
games that barely work and I don't
understand I don't get it yeah
so I really said Star Wars even had some
issues at launch they did uh see Star
Wars is a good game though you know uh
yeah
you can't have a game like redfall
that's average in a lot of ways and
doesn't really succeed at a lot of
things like I felt like
the environment was the best thing the
game had going for it like redfall
seemed like a very like
that's what I'm looking for like a
mystery town that I did want to learn
things from but yeah it didn't entice me
enough with the Vampire stuff to make me
care and then not to mention you know it
almost killed me so it's just like I
gotta choose my my safety in my life
over a video game like I still feel like
my eyes are gonna pop out from playing
that game last night maybe I do need to
turn down that uh
turn down that field of view maybe
that's what was doing it maybe you're
not supposed to play field of view with
30 frames yeah maybe that's what it is
yeah yeah because I didn't get nauseous
with it yeah yeah so I mean
God's hit me up to two out of Super Chat
what if Starfield gets delayed again I
would be very surprised the Starfield
gets delayed like extremely surprised
the odds of Starfield getting delayed
is I I feel very easily what would a
Starkville got delayed would you feel
away
yeah I'll be I'll be like really
disappointed like what the hell
you know what's what real quick Dirk
what's your top three games you're
looking for to Microsoft in order
um
well me personally
I'm really looking forward to the
hellblade 2 first then Starfield
and probably
Fable after that
100 fable 100 percent
I love Fable and I want them to do good
you know we got 457 people in the house
hit that like button man we got 111
likes I know some of you ain't for ain't
remember is a like button right below
the screen that you've seen me on it's
like it'll be like right here like below
this thing right here you know maybe
it's EOS maybe it's on your side I don't
know
you know go to the toilet I don't know
you were like you're like on the right
side
oh yeah I think I think hell plays good
and I think here's the thing
just because rightfall is underwhelming
to a lot of people including myself
doesn't mean Bethesda or Xbox is just
going to start delivering trash I don't
I don't I don't I don't agree with that
I think I think they're still going to
miss everyone still misses now the issue
is just you you missed it the wrong time
the worst time in the world that you
could have missed you missed
two dollars from Lord Metro all good
addict the game of the year launches May
the 12th salute
of course what do you think the odds
teams of the frame rate what do you
think the awesome Zelda winning game of
the year
pretty high actually since we're getting
close to that let's let's take a little
bit of your uh your sheet uh Metacritic
score for Zelda three point I'll give
you three point uh skill yet at 3.93 93
to 96.
no no 90 to 93 90 to 93. what do you
guys think of the chat
three points
I think I think
93 to 96.
get like a 97 98 yes I'm crazy bro 94 to
97. I let's see how many people
vote in in the in the 80s
we got one person that gave him one
point uh nine nine ninety eight to 101
okay Apollo 87 I see you
Ray Ray 23.
oh 23 frames is that what you're talking
about he said 22. yeah tears of the
frame rate 89 91 89 look people are
gonna start saying 89 because I said I
was looking for 80s
90 83 33.
you know it's gonna be crazy people are
going to completely forget about frames
in that game oh frame don't matter it's
not going to get talked about at all and
that's criminal it usually it says
something though
if rare fall dropped
say after say Starfield drops and it's
like a 88-89
hellblade 2 dropped and it's like a 88
89. then rare fall drop it wouldn't hurt
as bad
you know what I'm saying but because
right now people are questioning can
Xbox deliver some some quality games and
I think they can of course because we
just mentioned you know 2021 but the
timing the timing was like the worst
time
they could drop this game the
possibility
that's
Forza Starfield
and hellblade come out this year let's
say they do come out this year once they
all get above 90s
yeah that that that I would say the best
chance of that happening is Forza
ironically because I feel like Forza has
a pretty good
pretty good uh
formula to be able to get that 90. but
man if hell blade and Starfield either
one of them get a 90 plus but the thing
is
between your kids man like okay we got
Starfield and hellblade if you could dim
one of them to death by getting a 60
Minute credit but the other one succeeds
which one
oh my God what kind of question is that
you got to condemn one it gets a 60 but
you rotate that power to the other one
and it gets a 90 Plus
rather 92. I would rather
Starfield to get the higher
metacrity because it's going to be a
bigger guy
it's gonna be huge game Star field I
feel like he'll play getting the better
Metacritic would be better
oh you think so yeah because I feel like
Starfield I don't as long as far from
get a 60. let me correct that if that
would be devastating but I feel like if
Starfield is able to
just to deliver but hellblade comes out
and it's Innovative it's got really nice
combat it's got nice audio design nice
boss fights I feel like you're going to
get more of the audience that people
hate Xbox to Vibe with that more than
you would Starfield
because let's be wrote here the majority
of the people hating asses on Twitter 24
7. they all have PlayStations and what
does people love on Playstation third
person behind the shoulder action
adventure and if hellblade 2 does that
very well
there's a valid point shut up
I just saw somebody earlier say Xbox
needs to do a third person behind the
shoulder game
and the superhero game I said that's
that's PlayStation games let's get it
down PlayStation if that's what you want
yeah I just I just want
I have it's a bad time for Xbox right
now and they deserve to smoke they do
but it's like I said let's let's let's
roll this back a little bit you know
let's not act like the world's on fire
you know kids who did a good did bring
up a good point there hasn't been like a
game in the like the 60s
in like years for Xbox like remember
when they had every game almost coming
out was a 60
I think Crackdown three was the last one
yeah and that was it I think I
personally feel like this I feel like
crackdown's a better game than
I enjoyed uh Crackdown like the the
campaign I think I played the
multiplayer I enjoy the campaign
multiplayer was fine for three minutes
and yeah it got old
all right so you know we're gonna go
ahead and end this up start to slowly in
this up you know my answer a question or
two trying to burn like five minutes so
I can send you guys to fame you know
might as well burn five minutes so I can
send you a fight
what do you guys have questions for you
know I this is the one on only time I'm
gonna answer questions and don't answer
don't ask stupid questions all right
because if you ask stupid questions but
they're gonna get dirt
and we're sniped you're gonna get stupid
answers
oh oh okay I'm sorry it was my time to
get sniped
uh I would rather have
uh Tio uh tears of the Kingdom at 60 but
at least I don't pretend 35 is 45.
uh is angry today I'm sorry for cracking
yet is it
it's their hands ashy
no it's not ashy
what's up about the new Final Fantasy
I'm very skeptical of that game I wanted
to succeed
uh but final fantasies let me down for
like the past 10 years
you don't like the uh
so like the Final Fantasy games like you
don't like the action route that they've
been taking no it's not even just an
action I felt the foundation of Final
Fantasy is always the world the
character building the story and I feel
like they that sat in the back seat to
combat and graphics
um here's my question what is the damage
Starfield launches with typical Bethesda
Bethesda if okay here's the thing
there's a difference between a game
having bugs and a game being on uh
unplayable and having game breaking bugs
if the game comes out and it has like
light-headed bugs uh more funny than
anything like someone's head being big
they'll be fine and as long as the
game's good if the game's good they'll
be fine but the game comes out it's like
a Fallout 76 and no one likes it then
we're gonna have a different
conversation like listen Starfield would
be scrutinized even more because Xbox
owns them now
I hear Zelda leaked on the internet
what's the deal I think uh I think that
yes some some guy
yeah some guy posted that he's playing
Zelda and Reggie he's away Adam blocked
I don't know if you saw that he had
quoted the movie Taken
and he blocked him so he just says man
it it was pretty epic by the way he like
he had him blocked off of Twitter had
his account console bro that's crazy
would you rather play Final Fantasy X3
or persona 6. persona 6 all day long I I
love 10. Final Fantasy 10 is one of the
best final fantasies ever made but I
feel like X2 started dipping away from
what made Final Fantasy Final Fantasy
and I'm not confident three would put it
back in this track
uh
attic ever dipped back into RuneScape
it's I'm almost 20 years in yeah I play
it from a time did you ever play
RuneScape Dart no no I've never heard of
him bro it's like my first mm I really
love that game every now and I actually
had the client download it on my PC uh
but you know occasionally I jump in
there
uh would Disney Let Indiana Jones be in
Xbox schools that's a good question Dart
would Disney let them be exclusive ah
well it's got no problem letting
Spider-Man be I'm saying there's the Hey
listen you offering them enough money
Marvel Avengers uh whatever the alliance
Ultimate Alliance be exclusive for
switch yeah or like hotel right isn't
that a PlayStation exclusive
yeah
listen you pay them enough yeah they'll
they'll they'll let it be exclusive bro
so yeah I mean it's definitely possible
of course we don't know if it's
exclusive but it's definitely possible
someone said which Final Fantasy was the
Final Fantasy with the world I'm talking
about the code to a remake yeah yeah
yeah that's exclusive to PlayStation
yeah Sony better show awesome it's time
to remember Kotor looking horrible
oh yeah I'm gonna like be hitting the
gut if that game's bad because I love
that game and then I'm a I'm gonna look
at PlayStation and I'm gonna look at
Disney and I'm like why did you let them
make it
didn't have some development issues like
they didn't change teams or something
with that game something happened with
that game so like it was sometime but as
long as the government I don't care how
long it takes
what Xbox gets scrutinized if they push
back Starfield and drop hellblade 2
instead that's a good question do you
personally feel like now hold up there's
different scenarios if if hellblade's
good
and they Dr and they push back star food
now I think initially they're going to
get a lot of a lot of pushback like
before the game comes out but I do think
that if the game comes out in good
people will shut up
mm-hmm
if they push both back didn't give us
anything it'd be a lot of issues a lot
of issues
Final Fantasy 9 is my favorite yeah uh
zidane was a fantastic thing that would
be dumpster fire backlash I think it
would be a cute really bad backlash but
I think as long as the game was good
people would forget about it now people
would question thanks Lomo yeah slow mo
broke it down he said uh ask beer was
making cold tour but it but they got
fired because it was trash now the
support studio is the main studio so
yeah so that that game is probably still
years away bro uh someone said raindrop
to video yours happy with Xbox sit and
listen to it yeah we might
um someone had y'all think Spider-Man
will be successful for a third ghost
stopping in five years
I don't know what he means by that well
he's saying this is the third Spider-Man
in five years there's the third
Spider-Man game in five years
uh you know they do a really good job
implementing Venom I think people will
love it it's just but I do think people
will eventually get tired of that
gameplay and I think people are already
starting to get tired of the the Sony
template too uh I saw that after God of
War people saying they need to change it
up
um
where would you stand with Xbox they
were if they were to drop hellblade 2
and Starfield in 2024. uh it would be a
it would be really bad for them really
bad if they delayed both of those games
listen if hellblade drops in 2024 that's
fine early 2024 that's fine but
Starfield needs to drop this year bro
yeah and I want both of them this year
I'm gonna be greedy I want both of them
all right so uh go ahead and do your
outros dirt let's go ahead and get up
out of here
let's go ahead and get up out of here
um you said that real extra like
get out of here all right guys so yeah
um thanks man it was a fun show bro
appreciate you
you know these it's been a crazy time
man
or Bots like myself uh but the thing is
people need to realize too is it's gonna
people are gonna forget you know the
thing about the gaming industry is it
moves the mile minute
and you know absolutely as long as they
release games they could literally have
bad bad stuff from here till Starfield
comes out and Starfield comes out and it
hits like Skyrim did No One's Gonna care
yeah
and listen man and the gaming industry
is what have you done for me lately
industry if like you said if they drop
some some fire stuff
everybody gonna forget everything so
yeah hey freak can't hey hey Frank can't
man leave me alone man
I'm sensitive right now yeah put put
your put your stuff in there man I mean
yeah you know I'm on my phone I can't
spam it like you do
sorry put it in there once and I'll see
all right thank you sir
listen like uh said check out my channel
if you're a Xbox fan boy if you don't
mind little trash talking you probably
won't like my channel if you're a pony
you will be sniped my my mods I I call
them snipers because they will snipe you
if you come in there say Xbox or trash
let's bunch of trash
you know even some sometimes if you just
act like your opponent they might snipe
it and I might have to like bone slayed
last week was in there he was like he
wasn't being a pony
people that you noticed have been here
what the Mars noticed he wasn't a bot so
they kind of looked at him like hey man
what's up with this guy
it's like you just looking at him like
don't you do it don't you do it don't
you do
I tell people people say dirt
you got an echo chamber and I say so
sometimes you need an echo chamber
sometimes I'm hearing everybody yeah
you think about Echo Chambers how you
say what PlayStation content craze have
nothing but Echo Chambers that's it but
when the Xbox guy has it we're wrong so
absolutely you're at 100 right that's
why I said to hell with it yes I'm a buy
Channel yes I do the concert I got
sniped unbanned me
who said that dark Kermit
you know what's funny uh I don't know
man Jack boo Johnny he'll I'm blind you
for five dollars
it's like people keep asking me about
them so I started monetizing it I gotta
respect that though uh you can find me
on YouTube right here on that link guys
definitely go there uh sub to me I'm
posting a lot of content I got some
ideas I'm gonna do
um I hope you guys enjoy it I'm gonna
start uh putting a lot of put a lot of
time into that uh but one thing I am
going to do is I'm gonna send you guys
over there to uh Fame you know we
extended the show like five minutes just
so we can give you guys the thing go in
there tell them tell them addict sent
you man tell him that we extended the
show just to send him you guys tell him
addict and dirt sent you and we expect
what do we expect we expect some zeros
in our chat next week that's what we
expect some zeros but tell them the
addict
and dart sent you and you guys go over
there hit that like button if you do if
you don't want to stay man hit that like
button but tell them the attic show sent
you and I appreciate it for coming
through we'll see you next week and hit
that like button on your way out of here
peace out yo